we have a voicemail number that you can
call and leave me a voicemail
uh you can call it any time of day 219
to david p is the voicemail here's i've
gotten a lot of messages about
progressives and cryptocurrency lately
here's one such voicemail inquiring
about exactly that take a listen
hey david uh this is hubian i had a
question man
um so i'm pretty heavy into the crypto
space i am a progressive
but i found that there is a large
libertarian group
in crypto normally and one of their big
arguments
is that our traditional finance is going
to collapse because we're just putting a
ton of money
and inflation is going to go haywire i
i have my reservations about that
position and i would really appreciate
you
sort of just maybe maybe doing a deeper
analysis
on inflation generally in the economy as
with regard to how our government prints
money
i think it would be very insightful as
usual and would be very helpful to me
because then i just send them a link and
just say here
um consider this so thanks man i hope
y'all do
i've been watching you for like over a
half decade now it's kind of crazy to
think about but thanks
bye yeah these are good topics i mean
the thing about inflation
is um the first first of all the term
printing money at this point is so
antiquated i mean
we're really the government's not not
printing money we're talking about
digitally
creating money which you might say that
that's not that different than
than bitcoin and you would be right the
difference is it's a government
that is digitally creating us dollars
rather than um you know an algorithmic
process
with bitcoin that uh is creating it
um i am not big into the progressive
anti-cryptocurrency
movement i think that there are concerns
about cryptocurrency just like there are
concerns
with government-backed currencies the in
the the inflation spiral people
have been proven wrong i mean they've
just been proven wrong the united states
if you go back to tarp and the stimulus
under obama in 2009
um the the money supply has continued to
increase
in the united states what do you think
stimulus is fundamentally
and we've seen very well controlled
inflation in the united states
uh additionally our understanding of
modern monetary theory
continues to show that that the sort of
uh doom and gloom
inflation spiral claims are uh
the predictions just aren't bearing out
the same people have been making the
same predictions for a really long time
at some point we may get more inflation
in the united states but that's sort of
like the people who are constantly
predicting a crash
eventually they'll be right because
that's the way uh
capitalist economies work it's booms and
busts and at some point there there's
going to be a crash
some of the other criticisms of
cryptocurrency like for example
you know the energy usage of bitcoin
mining okay yeah i understand that
but traditional banking also has a
massive
energy and carbon footprint um
the the physical location components of
that banking
industry have huge environmental
implications
and the the other element of this that i
think is interesting
is as we switch over
um to alternative energy
the bitcoin can be mined with renewable
energy
as well so that one has never really
felt
felt great to me the general assessment
that bitcoin could collapse at any time
and it's only as good as people's demand
or interest in in holding it yeah i'm
absolutely that's absolutely true
and i've made no secret that i guess at
this point it's four and a half years
ago
i bought an amount of bitcoin that at
the time was sort of reasonably
calibrated to my financial
situation it's obviously gone 10x since
then
my assessment of the volatility of
bitcoin hasn't changed it's just
at this point it seems like it's here to
stay enough
that i want it to be a slice of my
portfolio and it's done well so far it
may not in the future
that wouldn't justify its existence one
way or the other
and it's really up to everybody to
decide what for for themselves
sort of what financial decisions make
sense but
uh so so i guess my takeaway is there
are good reasons to be skeptical of all
sorts of financial instruments
the stock market bitcoin currency
exchange whatever
um when i see particularly
um sort of hyperbolic arguments from
progressives
only applied to crypto when they could
apply elsewhere as well
it doesn't really inspire me to say yeah
that's exactly that's
more give me more of that please i think
that's where i am we've got a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about the elizabeth warren bernie
sanders new wealth tax proposal
we will also talk about a landmark
voting rights case before the supreme
court
we will talk about former french
president nicolas sarkozy being found
guilty of corruption
and much more so do yourselves a favor
and me
grab a membership at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show
and then you can join us there in mere
moments